foreign
[Music]
appears to be heading for its first
presidential election runoff with
counting from Sunday's vote in its final
stages president
remains short of the 50 needed to win
outright he says he'll respect any
decision to hold a second round Victoria
Gatenberg reports
[Music]
Turkish president
addressed supporters outside the
headquarters of the justice and
development party in Ankara it was his
first appearance since the polls closed
he told them he's ready for a runoff if
the election goes to a second round
we have seen that the margin with the
closest opponent is more than 2 million
votes and with the final result we will
see a wider margin we don't know if we
will have a runoff but if this is the
result of the first round the results of
the runoff will be the same if our
nation has decided to go to a second
round we will respect that decision
his main Challenger Kamal kilichterolu
leads a six-party opposition Alliance
that's determined to unseat erdogan he
urged supporters to be patient
despite his smear campaign against us
erdogan hasn't gotten the result he
wanted we have to wait for the final
results if the first round wasn't enough
to receive the Mandate we are going to
get it in the runoff election
election officials have been counting
the votes throughout the night a third
presidential candidate sin in Owen has
done better than expected analysts say
he has the potential to be king maker
one is an anti-immigrant anti-uh Refugee
candidate and I think it's basically a
new Epoch in Turkish politics because
both sides will Court him to get his
votes and they will have to do at least
something to satisfy his base and his
message
so far Owen is refusing to back either
erdogan or kilichterolu music
there will be another difficult 15 days
ahead of us and during this time if the
elections are completed with the current
results and go to the second round we
will do our best to make this process a
good one for our nation and our country
at this time we are not saying that we
will support one party or the other
erdogan has led turkey for two decades
overseeing growth in trade and foreign
investment as well as ambitious
infrastructure development projects but
more recently he's been criticized for
high inflation and the Turkish lira's
devaluation to the U.S dollar
[Applause]
kilichterolu says he wants to reform the
system of governance and return power to
Parliament a runoff vote will almost
certainly be needed to decide turkey's
future Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera
I want to take you to the Turkish
Capital anchor and that's for the
organization for security and
cooperation in Europe is going to be
holding a press conference the group's
been monitoring the election for
irregularities this is Michael George
link speaking he's the special
coordinator and leader of the short-term
Observer Mission they've had 28
long-term observers who've been deployed
throughout the country from April the
7th they've also had 14 International
experts based in Ankara itself let's
listen and of course following these two
important elections which we failed
which we witnessed yesterday
it is always for us an honor to be here
in this wonderful and hospitable country
where we are not observing elections for
the first time but therefore
because it's so tragic
please allow me to start by expressing
our condolences on the tragic loss of
life where so many lives have been lost
that occurred following the earthquakes
earlier this year this certainly makes
this observation a special one we are
here in full
conscience of the losses of the Turkish
people had suffered and that this is not
an easy situation
all of us observers were so impressed by
the overwhelming turnout in these
elections in this Centenary year of the
Turkish Republic the Turkish people have
clearly demonstrated their commitment
and their willingness to having the
decisive say in the future of this
country
now let me come to the contributions to
the main conclusions which we will share
with you today more completement
statement as you know will be available
and published
immediately after our statements
and therefore let me summarize from my
view the most important points
in the general elections held in the
wake of the devastating earthquakes
voters had a choice between genuine
political Alternatives and voter
participation was high
but the incumbent and the ruling parties
enjoyed an unjustified Advantage
including through biased media coverage
so the very genuine political
Alternatives but limited by non-level
playing field
in addition to this the continued
restrictions on fundamental and freedoms
of assembly Association and expression
hinder the participation of some
opposition politicians and parties civil
society and Independent Media in the
election process
nonetheless we found that the campaign
itself was competitive and largely free
for most contestants but was
characterized by intense polarization
and marked by harsh rhetoric instances
of misuse of administrative resources
and the pressure and intimidation faced
by especially one opposition party
the election Administration technically
managed the elections efficiently but
there was a lack of transparency and
communication as well as concern over
its independence
measures measures designed to facilitate
registration and voting for earthquake
affected citizens were limited placing
an additional burden on these voters to
exercise their voting rights
election day was generally well
organized and assessed possibly
positively by our observers however
instances of deficient implementation of
certain procedures particularly during
voting and Counting were noted
that's the overall picture but I want to
particularly highlight a few background
topics that brought us to these
conclusions
it's important that an important
background information that in practice
freedom of assembly Association and
expression are restricted by legislation
and that the independence of the
Judiciary remains a concern while we
note positively that the long-standing
recommendation to lower the
Parliamentary threshold was addressed
many other important recommendations
remain unaddressed turning to the
political scene yes the technical
registration of candidates technical
registration was managed inclusively but
still party dissolution proceedings
against the second largest opposition
party impeded its participation at the
criminal prosecution of some prominent
opposition politicians may also have
hindered their candidacy
such sort of politically motivated
interference in the electoral process is
not in line with International
commitments made by turkey air for
example in the ose or under the European
Convention of Human Rights
this applied also to some very prominent
individuals including the mayor of
Istanbul Mr marmolo and former hdp chair
co-chair demiotage
all in all let me sum up that in a
spirit of friendship and deep affection
to the Turkish people and to this
country we were observing and we were
trying to do the to the best of our
abilities our observation
in summing up let me say these were
competitive but still limited elections
as the criminalization of some political
forces including the Detention of
several opposition politicians prevented
full political pluralism and repeated
some individuals rights to run in
elections
that is why we said political
interference in the regular process is
not in line with turkey's International
covet Vincent that is what we measure
where the commitments are being
respected and the law is being respected
for the preliminary results we have seen
this election is not over we will
continue to observe also the second
round of the presidential election and
look forward to releasing further
conclusions at that time
thank you very much and over back over
to Katya
thank you very much we now move on to
Frank schwabe who heads the delegation
from pace
thank you very much
um
good afternoon so I refer to the text as
well but in addition I would like to say
that we were here as a council of Europe
with 39
members for the short-term election
observation I would like to thank the
osce order for the very good cooperation
because at the end we are in a way
depending on on the profit
professionality of this organization
um so I have to inform you that we were
invited by the authorities
um of this country due to the situation
that turkey is under monitoring uh in
the uh parliamentary assembly of the
Council of Europe we are prepared for
sure as well for a possible second round
um but we were here already for
pre-electual mission two days and we had
the opportunity to have a lot of
interlocutors from all over the society
the governmental parties the opposition
parties civil societies
um and so on and so on and we had the
opportunity to meet the central
electoral Council what unfortunately was
this time uh not uh not possible so the
country
have a lot of democratic challenges for
sure and we have a lot of
statements in our organization the
Council of Europe referring to this but
nevertheless I have to say as well like
Mr Link that we were impressed by the
height run out in this election and by
the possibility even when it's
problematic to run and uh to have an
election campaign for some parties and
some politicians that there was the
possibility of a competition you could
feel it at the election day that the
Turkish democracy
um is is breathing
um so I would say the Turkish democracy
is uh providing to be amazingly
resilient
um this shows the high turnout in the
election
but turkey does not fulfill the basic
principles of a democratic election for
sure as well Central political and
social actors are in prison
against judgments of the European Court
of Human Rights media freedom is
severely restricted and there's a
climate of self censorship so turkey has
a long way
from Far Fair election campaign
conditions and I really would like to
underline this because some people say
what has it to do with the with the
elections and with the election campaign
and our observation we have judgments
from the I would call it higher scrud in
Europe the European Court of Human
Rights and I'm really here to call the
authorities in the country which one
ever we will see
um to release those one who are in
prison and where is a very clear
judgment from the European Court of
Human Rights and the most important and
prominent examples are Osman cavalla and
celeration because this has to do
something with the Democratic
constitution in the situation
um in the in the country I have also to
remind the Turkish government on the
recommendations of the Venice commission
and Greco and other buddies of the
Council of Europe we talk already about
the question of media freedom I always
used when I go to election campaign to
switch on the TV even if I don't
understand the language but I get an
impression and when I switch on trt
Harbor maybe you are here
um I have really an impression that the
the current president was very much seen
in TV and we had a lot of talks
um together with Eric took the radio and
television High Council in the
pre-electural mission now in the mission
and to today I don't really understand
the rules very much and for sure it
brings a kind of situation of
self-censorship into the country and
this has to concern out again there was
a really high turnout and a generally
free access for voters to go to the
polling stations yesterday although
there were some situations I faced one
myself what was not very easy because
people were very nervous and this was my
um my assessment but anyhow it was
possible to vote we had restrictions for
sure very much for the hdp and for some
politicians we have to mention it and we
mention it in several reports of the
Council of Europe
what was a matter of concern was really
the situation yesterday evening and uh
and in the night where it was not really
clear how the situation was going on and
what was was really happening I think is
more clear today and really this I have
to ask the Supreme electoral Council who
have a very special method in this
country to be as much as transparent as
possible because I think was much more
transparency it would be able to prevent
such a situation again thank you very
much thank you very much for having us
here in this situation we try to do our
job our mandate impartial as possible
and thank you very much for the good
cooperation here
thank you
many thanks we now move on to Farah
Karimi who heads the delegation from the
osc PA
thank you Katia and thank you all for
joining us especially after a long
election day and night
so I want to express my deep
appreciation to my colleagues special
coordinator Michael link head of pace
delegation Frank Schwab and for their ex
and also Ambassador Jan Peterson for
their excellent cooperation throughout
our election observation mission
uh my name is Farah Academy and I am a
senator in the Dutch Senate and a member
of the osce Parliamentary assembly
it was an honor for me to help a team of
98 osce parliamentary assembly observers
from 26 different countries who came
together to observe the elections in
your beautiful country
I want to highlight that our teams were
warmly welcomed across the country not
just in Ankara but also in regions like
Istanbul Izmir one and the arbakir
and personally I had the privilege of
observing the process in jankaya and
elmadak and I extend my sincere
gratitude to everyone for their warm
Hospital hospitality
unfortunately I must address the
regrettable decision by the Turkish
government to deny accreditations to two
parliamentarians from Sweden and Denmark
while we respect a country's right to
control access to polling stations it is
important that the invitation to our
assembly to observe elections does not
influence the composition of the
observation missions
this decision based on the
parliamentarian's public opinion is
particularly disheartening
ladies and gentlemen I want to Echo the
statements made by my colleagues Mr Link
and Mr schwaba
in emphasizing that the despite the
availability of political alternatives
for Turkish people
these elections have seen unfair
advantages enjoyed by the incumbent
president and ruling parties
we are yet to know the final results
but in the event of a second
presidential round we will pay close
attention to ensuring a Level Playing
Field in our observations
throughout our mission we closely
monitored every step of the election day
process
from the opening of polling stations to
the voting and Counting
the polling stations we visited had a
remarkable voter turnout
showing the strong Democratic Spirit of
the Turkish people
I commend the dedication of everyone
involved including poll workers and
Civil Society
it is crucial
to address the significant
underrepresentation of women in Turkish
politics
I urge the next government Parliament
and political parties to take concrete
actions to ensure equal participation of
women in the country's political life
this can include introduce introducing
laws that guarantee an equal number of
male and female candidates on electoral
lists
I also want to express my appreciation
for the determination shown by those who
despite the challenges caused by recent
earthquakes made the effort to travel to
their damaged homes and vote
however it's concerning that the voter
turnout in earthquake affected areas was
lower
indicating that many people couldn't
vote
in case of a second round of the
presidential election we hope concrete
measures will be taken to ensure
everyone can exercise their right to
vote
the government should also take
additional steps to support individuals
facing difficulties during such critical
circumstances ladies and gentlemen thank
you for your attention and of course I
am ready to answer any question you may
have
thank you very much and last but not
least from the podium we turn to
Ambassador Jan Peterson who heads the
mission of the international Observer
Mission from odesside
thank you very much and enjoy my
colleagues in welcome you
all of you and thank you for your
interest in our book
first of all I would like to Begin by
thanking the Turkish authorities for
inviting us to observe
and I'd also like to thank our partners
in the international election
observation Mission from the OC
parliamentary assembly as well as the
Parliamentary assembly of the Council of
Europe for their excellent cooperation
and especially our coordinator Mr Ling
before I go into our findings in more
detail I'd like to emphasize the fact
that I and a team of election experts
have been in Turkey since late March
with a 28 long-term observers arriving
just a week later to observe around the
country
in this period of six weeks we have
therefore had the opportunity to observe
the run-up to the elections closely
and to hold numerous meetings with
officials as well as representatives of
the election authorities political
parties civil society and the media
further 213 short-term observers joined
us last week
enabling us to make a comprehensive
statistical assessment of the voting
process on the election day
and to go into a few key points in more
detail
first of all I would like to
congratulate the people of turkey for
their Democratic Spirit which was
illustrated by the high turnout on
Election Day
voters had a choice to make between
genuine political Alternatives and the
campaign period was mostly peaceful with
most candidates campaigning freely
at the same time the election
administration led by the Supreme
election Council
worked efficiently and then mostly
within the set legal deadlines
this was no small feat given the
challenges of the devastating
earthquakes That Shook this country just
a few months ago
these are all positive elements in the
process running up to yesterday's
election and I'm glad to be able to draw
your attention to them here today
however
there are other elements so our
assessment that are regulatively more
negative
I just mentioned the election
Administration
notwithstanding its efficiency it worked
its work was marked by the by lack of
transparency
inadequate communication and concern
over Independence
not only were sessions of the Supreme
Election Commission and mid-level
election Council not held in public
but the Supreme election Council also
faced failed to publish most of his
decisions despite the legal obligation
to do so
another area of concern was the pressure
on opposition politicians and parties
which was a series of tackle to the
participation in the election
the green left party Faith faced
widespread intimidation and even the
rest of its supporters with goals
against International standards and
severely obstructed the party's campaign
opportunities
long-standing concerned about the
respect for fundamental freedoms of the
assembly Association and expression
which are all key to democracy were not
dealt with during the election period
and all those also the Constitution
guarantees the independence of the
Judiciary many of the people to whom we
spoke from across a wide spectrum of
society continued to raise concerns that
this Independence is not being upheld
and then
a final point an important point I would
like to make
from other long-term observation
concerns the media
of the campaign
in our assessment the freedom of
expression and the media also protected
by the Constitution
is limited by a number of laws
the recent criminally realization of
disseminational false information
the fact that websites are frequently
blocked on online content removed and
the ongoing arrests and prosecutions of
journalists further week in freedom of
expression
unfortunately we also noted that the
public broadcasting clearly favored the
ruling parties and their candidates
during the campaign despite his
constitutional obligation to remain
impartial
the majority of private National TV
channels were monitored as part of our
observation we're also clearly biased to
watch the ruling parties in their
coverage
I'd like to make a final point on the
elections election day itself
voting day was mostly peaceful also
there were a number of incidents in and
around polling stations
all those process was generally well
organized of service reported that
safeguards such as a ceiling of ballot
boxes and verifying voter ID were not
always implemented in the addition
in some polling stations the layout did
not fully guarantee the secrecy of the
vote
and family and group voting were
frequent unfortunately over half of the
polling stations were not fully
accessible for persons with disabilities
these are some of the key points from
other observations which I know have
mentioned that began already in March
however there are many more points in
our report with with the initial
findings of the in of the international
Observer mission
and I would recommend that you take a
copy together with the press release on
your way out
and before I finished a heartful thanks
to the team working with me here in
Ankara as well as the long and
short-term observers spread out across
the country
and thank you again for coming and I as
well ready to answer your questions
thank you
you're watching Al Jazeera we've been
bringing you live pictures from Ankara
where the organization for security and
cooperation in Europe has been
announcing its preliminary findings
because it has been monitoring the
process of the turkey elections over the
last 24-48 hours but they've actually
had um observers in country from about
April the 7th we just heard the uh head
of the election Observer Mission Jan
Peterson the Ambassador there outlining
some of the main key points that have
been brought up by all the speakers that
we've seen they've been impressed by the
uh the turnout of Voters to the
elections and they've also had concerns
about media bias in the run-up to the
elections that Michael George link the
leader of the short-term Observer
Mission described it as an unlevel
playing field but he said they have also
all referred to intimidation faced by
opposition
politicians as well again in the run-up
to this I want to go to uh who's alive
for us in Ankara one would imagine that
the opposition is is going to be paying
very close attention to this to see if
there's anything there that they're
going to be able to use in their
response as we head towards the the
second election that we're going to see
in future
well Rob now the opposition is saying
that it's confident it is going to go
for a runoff and but still it has been
expressing concerns over the ballot
those concerns were echoed today at the
press conference by the organization of
the security and cooperation in Europe
with this Ambassador Jan Peterson
talking about issues that turkey has to
tackle in the future particularly when
it comes to the restrictions placed on
political parties opposition figures the
Detention of politicians and they say
this is not something that could be
conducive to uh freedom of expression
freedom of assembly and pluralism in the
country and they say that the government
candidates were given unjustified
greater access particularly to state run
media something the opposition leaders
have been repeating timer and again and
I think these are issues which are going
to definitely be top priorities for the
international observers who will be
there for a runoff but also for the
opposition because when you look uh at
the uh at the percentage of the votes as
we speak president erdoran at 49
trailed by opposition leader kabalist by
44 you're getting greater indication
that this is going to be also an
extremely delicate tense runoff where
all the parties say we need equal access
to Media to be able to
send our message to the people so that
people understand what we are for what
do we stand for and vote for us
about just nearly 45 of the vote there's
already been some criticism coming out
of his performance and that of some of
the the opposition as well what does
this mean for the unity of the
opposition because of course that was
key in the run-up to this latest
election
it's a it's an opposition coalition
whose future hangs by a threat because
the it was extremely difficult to bring
them together to move forward and I
think their main goal was basically
toppling president
they have never managed to set aside
their differences about wide range of
issues economy politics and foreign
policy the biggest problem now would be
a foreign to hold them together for the
runoff but when it comes to the runoff
you have a problem here if they are for
example going to build Bridges with the
third candidates in an uh Oran this is
not something which is going to please
the other components of the opposition
number two if they decide to convince
people across the country for
uh more votes you might have different
views about who should have a bigger say
in the future this means that the
Coalition will continue to be fragile
for the upcoming weeks and months Hashem
thank you very much indeed that's
talking to us from Ankara we've just
been listening to the organization for
security and cooperation in Europe which
has been giving its assessment of the
Turkish elections which have just been
going on in the last 48 hours or so I'm
going to be back in about 30 minutes
with more on this story and others I'm
Rob Matheson stay with us